all right method one this quadrant
negative two with the unit circle this
is 3d glasses now in all my time
teaching your line on top of it what I
find is people hate graphic people say
to me wrapping takes so long of graphing
is hard and these have to get up because
it takes a long time computer practices
and that's why you find it hard because
you don't justices right my solution is
don't go away from something which
clearly you're going to get anyway if
you're going to have to develop this
skill you might go
did you healed him develop it and then
it will become useful to you in lots of
other ways like this one sorry
at some point last year you would have
been introduced to what the sine graph
looks like and I want to show it to you
again I'm not going to draw the whole
line graph which way up and down forever
I'm just going to draw apart from north
to 350 because that's the part area okay
so looks like this okay a couple of
things to point out while we're just
looking at the trap number one it is
smooth number two it has these spots
where it sort of curls around gently you
notice that those are not sharp points
they are gentle curve just like a
parabola okay
lastly you'll notice that even though it
kind of looks like to hard work and one
down those are not semi circles they're
not so exactly as if you draw something
that looks like this it is not the sizer
it might look nice but it's not the sine
curve and when we go on later to learn
our calculus and differentiation you'll
realize why is it so critically mistaken
okay but essentially what that means is
CV on point where it cuts the axis see
those intercepts how to look at the
gradient bit I'll see how it's like Adam
angle yep
let's add an angle there and a little
bit lost straight up in there
okay so this is what Y cosine X looks
like label that and such and white is
assignment your box of intercepts
I went from North to 360 which makes
that plug in the middle 180 okay which
by the way if you remember how to look
at the unit circle again where is theta
equals 180 e on the unit circle
describers you start from the positive
x-axis and then you start turning start
turning and then there buddy
you're green so therefore this is the
point do you see why if you look at this
guy y sine 180 in zero what site about
it that's the y coordinate
what's two up and down in this point and
so zero right and that also tells you
why side 360 is also zero so what went
inside 360 is it's going to be way back
at the start
where are you up and down and some 0
alright that's what we got some fine
it's creepy now you're on Team this sine
theta equal to hot once you're really on
TV witness that ground in sex with this
one so just one for thought I'm going to
draw y equals 1/2 on here
nothing firmer what's the highest sign
goes what's this value I want up here
it's more isn't it by the way come back
to the unit circle why is the highest
and guess what
because the radius of the unit circle is
one the highest I have a diagram in this
one and the y coordinate is one which is
also why the lower position is negative
1/2 this down here is that offense okay
Tom Burton scale and here under
amplitude so that means where is y
equals 1/2 well it's halfway up isn't it
get a half degree that my flavors okay
so get your ruler out and draw a wire
goes all the way across like that and
just like we begin circle essentially
what you are doing now is solving
simultaneous equation as you then use
this equation let's call that guy
equation one and then I've given you
this equation and I'm going to call him
equation two right
I just love why the 1/2 is the Green
Line and y equals sine X is a black one
so if you great got given two cases or
one pair of pallantides equation you
look like that in solve by substitution
what is she your subdued whines or the
other and then you'd write this that's
what it looks like other so looking for
points of intersection how many other
true which is hurt that we know right
now okay and where are they they're
young and she are okay now again what I
love about this is you don't even have
to think about quadrants right
look where the solutions are do you see
one of them is an acute angle between
north and night and the other one is
going to be an optician between buying
one hate underneath reason as a memorize
of arbitrary ast speeds in the graph
just does the work for you
then you say where these just want PR
and here okay again you can use your
calculator if you can't remember your
exact values but your solution sure
enough is going to be see it Bezier is
present in fact if you join our self a
decent tie graph it's actually quite
easy to read metal see that this piece
needed here is Milka 90 that's not a
third you're great so 30 degrees is my
first position
now again look at the symmetry of the
graph so we want to me or you know are
worried about these on this and then
we'll create the victim under my network
to effect okay look at what cases book
with g notice to scienter had always
wonderful beautiful symmetry to it right
the reason it has so much symmetry to it
is that the unit circle have so much to
determine the insisting that integrally
connected okay
in position is all forty seconds to get
about this parliament just look at
what's left okay that bottom part
because i know will give me any solution
right why do I know
they never intersect like science big
are healthy positives to on the ball
only the part about being with me now
just look at them you see how that's
symmetrical that's a symmetrical object
so if I got this solution the first one
by going 30 degrees that way how do I
get the second solution by doing degrees
the other way that's why it's 180
degrees minus theta because you're
starting from here and going to the left
Jersey you see this is what I mean you
can memorize this again you can memorize
the machinery without knowing why it
works the reason why it works is because
of this picture so therefore from the
graph my solutions are I don't really
need to say anything else apart from me
here really that's the wonderful thing
about method to and methods 3 they
pretty much cut out all of this coming
around random rules of reasons that no
one really knows no one GySgt boys -
what was - not me either and it just
said look the pitch speaks for itself
sine theta in the white corner is the
heart or siphon started you know I'm
excited is this grass
Wednesday keep wanting to the hump and
stop their head and that's a solution I
will in fact they tell you that
all right
and then you get your solution